today I want to talk to you about why
most entrepreneurs were once beggars I'm
Patrick many of your hosts evalute and
weekly and today I want to talk to you
about why most entrepreneurs were once
beggars I want you to think about it
this way imagine when a boy reaches
puberty right think about that age when
a boy realizes hey I like girls and he
wants to date girls and there's normally
a girl in school he likes than normally
young boys they fall in love every other
minute most boys or men know when we
were boys every other minute you're in
love with somebody new not all of this
all of this all that and so a lot of
times a boy will beg a girl to date her
and right and girls don't like beggars
they don't like a guy that bets for
somebody to datum okay let's just say
eventually a girl says yes I'll go on a
date with you and they start dating they
become boyfriend/girlfriend dance
sometimes a boy or a girl may manage the
other person right and when you manage
somebody what happens you're hovering
over them you're trying to control them
what typically happens to that
relationship you lose them and
eventually a man leads a relationship
and here's why
I'm a leader the same goes in every
single thing with business and startup
entrepreneurs because here's how it
works
typically when somebody starts in sales
or business if you're in business you're
salesman if you're an entrepreneur
you're selling something you're selling
an ID or selling the concept you're
selling why your idea is a great idea
for somebody in business within a new
entrepreneur or a new businessman also
goes through the same thing as well they
go through the process of please do
business with me please buy from me
please look at this up please take a
look at this please unbaked please
please please and that's fine
Google war plays a powerful word every
and everybody starts off begging don't
think this as a bad thing this is not
the idea of saying well I should stop
begging that's um what I'm telling you
we all in one way or another asking for
help from other people right please can
you take a look at this okay so people
do
then they get some clients or they get
some agents or they get some employees
or they get some so they get some people
that want to work with them the second
mistake they make is they start managing
and controlling what they got that
becomes a little bit too much that when
you try to manage and control you how
you somehow someway tend to lose what
you already begged initially to gum who
comes in and work with you and
eventually eventually an entrepreneur or
something gets to a phase where they
lead their clients they lead their sales
reps they lead their employees they lead
their teams and that's when it starts
expanding bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger so my challenge to
you is this today if your startup
entrepreneur if you new entrepreneurs if
a new business person I understand
there's a face of begging but when you
get to the managing part and you got to
manage there's still a part of
management with your business do not
spend 90% of your time managing spend
90% of your time of leading and spend
10% of your time managing your business
you have graduated from the begging part
because you have created or reputation
where people say this is somebody to be
in business with and if you do 90% of
leading 10% managing you should have a
pretty successful career as a business
owner or an entrepreneur for a long time
to come my message of the week employees
be sure to visit Patrick bet David calm
and subscribe to my weekly newsletter